this morning on the dish from small town
girl to big city chef and back again
that describes kelsey barnard clark and
her journey from alabama to the culinary
institute of america to some of new
york's top restaurants our very own
jamie wax paid her a visit good morning
jamie good morning my friend that's
right clark is now back home blending
all that experience with a healthy dose
of southern hospitality at her
restaurant and in her new cookbook i
talked with her about that and the
cooking show win that put her on the
culinary map
fried chicken and champagne is
definitely like the last meal i would
eat before i die probably maybe throw
some caviar on there just in case why
not of all the many places chef kelsey
barnard clark has cooked the very finest
meal you might get is in her favorite
spot her home
but what a beautiful southern home thank
you it's where we sat down to an opulent
spread of southern cuisine
sweet corn with paprika cheese and
citrus southern biscuits shrimp with
succotash
deviled eggs playfully called wicked
chickens
one time someone made a joke to me they
said do you know why we call them wicked
chickens i was like no
and they said because wicked chickens
make the best deviled eggs i was like oh
okay
i am a huge deviled egg fam this is by
far one of the very most delicious i've
ever had the smokiness of the brisket
and then the brininess of the okra and
then you've got a hit of pimento cheese
which is just perfect it creates this
profile that is a deviled egg but it's
it's so much more you can't get more
classic southern than okra and pimento
cheese the other thing i notice about
your cooking
is it's not just the profile of these
foods that are beautiful but it's so
much about texture a lot of southern
recipes lack herbs
they like acid and they lack texture a
lot of times you'll see me adding
crunchy things and there's always herbs
on everything i do i'm a big big fan of
herbs this is one of my favorite meals
like to eat personally i ate it for
lunch yesterday i was making it actually
it's succotash and then i love shrimp so
much so you top it with shrimp if there
was a dish that kind of described me it
would probably be this
and a hallmark of southern cuisine
perfectly fried chicken this was taught
to me all right i can't wait because
then you hear that that's what you want
to hear
yeah oh i mean so juicy
and it's it's so beautifully crispy and
fried it's that marriage where you can't
tell
where the skin ends and the crust begins
clark grew up in alabama showing an
interest in food at a very early age
after graduating from the culinary
institute of america she began cooking
in some of the most respected kitchens
in new york
when i was working at cafe boulud i was
responsible for family meal which in our
industry is cooking for each other right
i was working under gavin cason and he
was executive chef and he was like i
want you to cook your food quit cooking
everybody else says cook your food and i
was like
oh okay i gotta cook gumbo they call my
mom's like what's the gummy recipe i
don't remember so she had to type it out
and i coat gumbo and then it just was
one of those things i would just
remember making the roux in that kitchen
being
kind of going this is crazy and why
didn't i ever write this down this is a
moment every single
southern
home chef will
relate to in this story right now
after her time in new york with
everywhere to choose from
she chose to continue her vision back
home in dothan alabama my plan was to go
to new orleans and so i was coming home
for just a breather because i was burned
out truly i said you know what i'm going
to cater for a little bit because the
caterer that i'd worked for he was my
mentor and he had passed away and there
was this huge void for fine dining
catering here and you know rest is
history didn't leave i ended up getting
here i was fully booked for a year in
about a month and there was just this
wow oh yeah and i had this moment of
like why am i so acting like i'm so
against my town when they are so
unbelievably supportive of me
and i think that that's just where this
all started order up hayden
from there she opened her restaurant kbc
you know when i was in high school we
didn't there was nothing not a single
business here attracting other
businesses to a now thriving downtown i
mean this downtown area and this main
street survived the pandemic yes which
is
i mean what a blessing to even be able
to say that my restaurant survived it
which most of my friends didn't
when the opportunity came to compete on
top chef it meant she had to leave
behind her husband and then 10 month old
son for the duration
the sacrifice paid off and clark took
home the big prize
kelsey
you are top chef
i think for me it was it was a life
lesson more than it was about the food
and and it was just a wonderful
experience because when in your life do
you get to go somewhere
and anyone you've ever respected admired
wanted to learn from is
actually doing it with you for 10 weeks
all right
this is your last two and she's used the
exposure she got from her wind to spread
the message that southern cooking and
hospitality should be inclusive of
everyone it is incredibly important for
me
at kbc it is always a perfect picture of
what culture should look like and i
think that that's the really cool thing
about this new era we're in
is southern hospitality reaching farther
than we thought it would reach is it
important to you that you're a major
voice in that oh it is probably the most
important thing to me the lessons and
recipes she's drawn from southern
culture are now the basis for her new
cookbook southern grit and i've been a
collector of cookbooks since i was 12
years old so that's really what i always
think back on when i see this book now
on my shelf with all the other ones i'm
like whoa i wrote a book read a cookbook
someone's reading this you know you
don't want a ton of breading but it's
breaded enough when it's no longer wet
the most fun thing about cooking is
teaching people and hopefully inspiring
someone to love to cook one day
and for clark staying inspired herself
is everything i haven't even gotten
started yet that's how i really feel to
me
there's never like a stopping point you
got to keep getting better and pushing
yourself and learning more and got to
keep going finding a new thing and then
getting really good at it and that's
sort of
always my goal being in the moment being
in the moment and
never settling for
just now
uh we have a beautiful spread from her
literally we've got this pimento cheese
cheese straws which are such a great
southern appetizer and finger food and
then pepper jelly and it's all meant to
go together the cheese fries in that's
it then you got the sparkling sangria
she's just she is a wonderful advocate
for diversity in southern cooking for
the complicated history of southern
cooking but she's just a great chef
awesome